over the course of a single year
the world has changed in ways that few
could have imagined
but some did warn the risks of a
pandemic and we're all still wrestling
with how to cope with coronavirus
so are we repeating now some of the
mistakes we made at the start
this is coveted crisis learning the
[Music]
lessons
[Music]
good evening i'm sophie ridge over the
next hour we'll be examining the
strategies used to try and defeat the
virus
while protecting the nhs and the economy
based on the most comprehensive timeline
yet assembled of the uk's response
and will ask whether we're making better
decisions as we grapple
with the second wave of cobit 19. with
us tonight the former health secretary
and current chair
of the house select committee jeremy
hunt plus the chair of the nhs
confederation lord victor adebowali
joining them as we analyze the key
moments the big decisions and the data
are the former head of testing at nhs
test and trace
also chief executive at birmingham
women's and children's hospital sarah
jane marsh
and the deputy chair of the joint
committee on vaccination
and immunisation professor anthony
hardin
we'll speak to them in just a moment but
first the government's
overarching aim has been to reduce
deaths and prevent the nhs from becoming
overwhelmed
but from the problems around ppe to the
pressures around supporting the economy
and the success of the vaccine rollout
is have mixed results
i know that there are plenty of things
that people will say
we got wrong of course there must be
time
to learn the lessons and we will
but i also know that some things went
right
and emphatically right imagine
everything you love
but then set it on fire the first lot
was a nightmare because i had to bear
guys back on the streets if you've not
got the adequate ppe
the system will fail at that point we
know that there's a light there we just
can't quite see it yet
it's the biggest day that we've had in
terms of falls since
1987. who was expecting this to happen
you know for the first time
in our history the government is going
to help to pay people's wages if you
produce a ventilator then we will buy it
the distribution
element has been a little bit tricky the
united
the nhs we st everyone to treat ppe like
the precious resource
that it is why we're having to struggle
to get this equipment in place
it's appalling really the only job i've
really had since
college so i'm not really sure what
we're all gonna do i can't do another
two weeks inside
in oxford human clinical trials are
beginning in a mission to develop a
possible vaccine
i have a simple message download the app
we're getting told that
every staff member in healthcare will be
tested it's alive we don't even
know how many nhs staff are off sick we
have
met our goal 122 347 tests
all of my gigs from last year got
cancelled
this is a government scheme designed to
get people back eating out
after 12 billion pounds why does the
prime minister think that his track and
trace system
has gone so wrong this could be the end
of the road for my business this care
home
is now full of nhs patients teams
working in tandem to maintain
the barrier leading into the hot zone we
learned a lot from that first wave
we learned some of the treatments that
help the chancellor has extended
the furlough scheme we all rely on this
so much even more now if i lose my job
i'm not getting an other one the uk is
facing a significant recession we've
stopped short of having total
closure of the border the uk covert 19
vaccine rollout
has begun when those vaccines have
finally freed us from this virus we will
make sure we learn
the lessons
now we'll get into the detail shortly
but first i just want to ask all i guess
the same question that we began with
last night
what for you is the single moment or
memory that stands out as significant
over the last year jeremy hunt to you
first
well i think the saddest one was when
the first doctor died i think it was a
an organ transplant donor back in march
but the one that's really stuck in my
mind has actually been the moment that
sir tom
moore was knighted uh that was just such
a
a british occasion in extraordinary
times i don't think anyone who saw that
will ever forget it
yeah i think it was such an incredible
moment for all of us
what captain tom did uh victor adeboye
to you uh
next what's the one memory that really
stands out for you
there's so many that stick with you but
um
i guess on individual basis it was the
um
what happened to belly ginger who was a
ticket
um front-line ticket officer at king's
cross
and someone abused her and coughed and
spat at her
and she died of kokovov at the age of 47
her colleague got clothed and recovered
and for me he just told us the story of
the frontline workers
not just my colleagues in the nhs but
also those colleagues that are
supporting
um nhs uh workers getting to work and
just
just trying to do their jobs i guess the
other thing is when
we had the the stopping of elective
surgery
because at that point we knew that the
nhs was at real risk of being
have been overwhelmed and as we stand
we've got 4.6 million people
on the waiting list and and that is
something that we have written to the
prime minister about because
any recovery has to take into account
the sheer weight
um on nhs staff at this moment in time
certainly something that we should get
into
later on the program as well a really
important point um let's go to sarah j
marsh now what's the one significant
moment for you that sticks out from the
last 12 months
for me sophie it was standing in front
of the hospital i'm chief exec of
birmingham women's and children's
and watching as one of our much-loved
consultants
vishwasaya was brought in front of the
hospital with all the staff tapping
as part of his final journey because he
was the first member of staff at
birmingham women's and children's who
died of kovid
and then watching his beautiful wife and
daughter get out the car
and just come to me and say thank you
for everything that you've done for fish
when it was bish that had done
everything for us
that's a moment that no family should
have to go through
no body that works in the nhs should
have to go through
and it was just it was just such a
pivotal moment
and um yeah it'll stick with me forever
and
we'll obviously miss fish forever thank
you for sharing such a personal
story it does feel really important to
bring it back to those
individual stories as well when we're
talking through the data and everything
and just remember it's about people
primarily and professor handen what
moment sticks out for you
well i have two moments sophie by may
the first moment is on the 30th of
december uh when we
approved the astra or oxford astrazeneca
vaccine
and made the bold decision on jcbi to
have a delayed
secondary strategy so we could immunize
millions of people
that was a really pivotal moment in our
fight against coronavirus my personal
moment was
on the 12th of march three days after my
60th birthday when i developed covlid
and and then suffered a number of
complications including
having to go up and down to hospital on
four occasions so
my personal experience of covert has
really lived with me
and has reminded me right way through
this vaccination program my
determination
that we protect as many people as
quickly as possible
against this awful virus sorry to hear
about your illness are you feeling
okay now well i i i've had a form of
long coverage
i'm feeling i would say 85 better but
i'm still not fully recovered even
11 months later which is a real solitary
lesson
for what covid can do to people um have
you been previously completely fit and
well
so so yes i'm much much better thank you
very much but but
but i'd like to be so fit that i went
back onto my mountain bike and was able
to do everything i could do before i
i developed it but it will come i'm sure
hopefully not long at all and thank you
all for sharing and
such a important range of memories and
moments thank you
now from the start the manta was clear
to protect the nhs
but of course there were and still are
many other issues to
consider and as our timeline makes
vividly clear the various different
priorities often
competed with each other and some safety
measures notably the vaccine rollout
have been more successful than others
like the test and trace system or the
ppe shortage
at the start of the pandemic well let's
talk about ppe
first because on the 7th of february the
world health organization announces a
severe global disruption
in the supply of personal protective
equipment and says
priority should go to health workers
closely followed by those who are sick
or caring for someone who is sick
and on the 25th of february the uk
government issues
this guidance it remains very unlikely
that people receiving care in a care
home
or the community will become infected
people in care settings
are not advised to wear face masks now
that changes two and a half weeks later
when on the 13th of march the government
publishes new guidance saying that ppe
should now be used for close personal
contacts such as washing and bathing
personal hygiene and contact with bodily
fluids
on the 10th of april with stories of
inadequate pp mounting
matt hancock says there is a herculean
effort underway
to get vital supplies to frontline
workers but it's not all bad because on
the 23rd of april
the first human trials of the
coronavirus vaccine in europe begin
in oxford well ahead of many people's
expectations
and it's confirmed that the uk will get
the astrazeneca vaccine
first back to ppe and on the 28th of
april we get new guidance
saying that care home staff should use
it regardless of whether residents in
your care home
have symptoms of covid19 or not now
remember this is
two months after the government said
people living in care homes were not
likely to become infected
now by now it's clear from countries
who've successfully contained the virus
contact tracing is key and on the 5th of
may
the first version of the nhs contact
tracing app enters a trial phase
on the isle of wight but at the same
time the scale of the problem in the
care sector
is starting to become clear on the day
that the office of national statistics
revealed
over 40 percent of cover deaths are
occurring in care homes
a sky news investigation exposes the
depths of the crisis in care
the social care system was in crisis
long before coronavirus
arrived and social care providers say
that it will now
shine a light on some of the pressures
that they've been facing in recent years
and long after the pandemic has died
down the government will be
once again under pressure to reform this
entire system
well let's go back to test and trace and
on the 21st of may sage warns
that the system will become overwhelmed
if it's launched during a time of high
prevalence
of covert 19 and on the same day the nhs
confederation warned that time is
running out
to get it up and running a week later
the testing of people with suspected
coronavirus
becomes part of the official nhs test
and trace program but
mps are told it won't be fully
operational until the end of june
and it quickly becomes overwhelmed now
on the 18th of june matt hancock says
the
government is abandoning the development
of its own contact tracing app focusing
instead on apple and google technology
despite previously saying
it wasn't good enough good news though
on the 20th of july with the uk
securing 30 million doses of the pfizer
biontech vaccine
the first such agreement signed in the
world
now despite not having a functioning
test and trace system the
summer was characterized by initiatives
to reopen
the economy over the bank holiday
weekend alone
44.6 million meals would be claimed
through the eat out to help out scheme
but a month
later and deaths are rising
again and it isn't until the 24th of
september that the nhs contact tracing
app
finally launches in england and wales
now let's fast forward to the 2nd
of december and a major breakthrough as
the uk becomes the first country in the
world
to approve the pfizer biontech vaccine
and margaret keenan becomes the first
person to get the jab on the 8th of
december
as the rollout of vaccinations begins
but then
on the 14th matt hancock announces that
a new variant the virus has been
identified in the south of england
with over a thousand cases detected so
far
on the 30th of december uk regulators
approved the oxford astrazeneca vaccine
for use
it's also the day that the joint
committee of vaccination
and immunization increases the gap
between the first and second doses of
vaccines
to try and increase uptake and now it's
a race against time
on the 22nd of january with around six
million people vaccinated already
and deaths close to a hundred thousand
new research from the government's virus
experts revealed the so-called variant
of concern
is likely to lead to an increased
risk of death now let's bring in
our panel at this point shall we uh
jeremy hunt to you
first do you think that the success of
the vaccine
roll out will help perhaps people forget
some of the failures of what's happened
over the last year particularly
on ppe intestine trace
well we need to remember everything
that's happened because we've got to
learn the lessons from it and the the
biggest lesson of all
is that in a pandemic you have to act
faster than the virus
and we were too slow to lock down we
were too slow
to get ppe problems sorted out and to
get the test and trace capacity up and
running
but we've been one of the fastest in the
world when it comes to vaccine approval
and distribution and that i think is our
great hope
providing we can get this vaccine out to
the majority of the population before we
see any variants
arrive in the uk that that may
potentially be immune to some of the
vaccines then if we can get
the case levels down quickly enough
we've got a chance of succeeding and
really being proud of the fact that in
this area uh
britain has been the fastest and most
successful country of its size anywhere
in the world
you say that we were too slow to lock
down but it seems to me that part of the
reason we were too slow to lock down was
because we were following the wrong plan
the pandemic plan for a flu
epidemic not something like coronavirus
when you were
the longest serving house secretary
don't you have to take some
responsibility
for nhs planning as well yes i do
and we planned extensively for pandemics
in fact we were rated the second best
prepared country in the world by johns
hopkins university in
the united states but we now know that
we were planning for a flu pandemic and
there was a group think not just
in the uk but i think across western
europe and north america
that pandemics are likely to be flu
we obviously know that's not the case
now but that group thing
crucially did not exist when it came to
vaccines
where the original planning for the
oxford astrazeneca
vaccine started back in 2016 under chris
whittie's leadership because he used to
work at the department for international
development after the ebola
crisis in which uh we've started to fund
the development of a vaccine for the
mers virus and that proved very helpful
in developing the astrozenica oxford
astrozenica virus so
i think what we've learned is that we've
got to be
much more open-minded to the kind of
virus
that we might be subjected to and uh
being better at horizon scanning across
the whole world
and really thinking what the risks are
is definitely going to be one of the
most important lessons
well let's talk about vaccines a bit
further shall we and we can bring in
professor
handen at this point the wh show the
world health organization really backing
the oxford astrazeneca jab today but
there have been concerns
about how well it works against the
south africa variant how worried should
we be
well i i think we should be concerned
but not worried
we do know that this was a very small
study in south africa which looked at
very young people and showed that it
wasn't so effective the vaccine against
mild disease
but all the evidence shows that this
vaccine is highly protective
against severe disease hospitalization
and death
and so and we do know that the
predominant
uh variant strain circulating in the uk
at the moment which is the
the kent virus is
very sensitive against the vaccine and
very sensitive
against hospitalizations and deaths we
know that there are small
pockets of the south african variant um
circulating in the uk but we do believe
that that
virus is not quite as transmissible as
the ken
variant and therefore it is likely in
the next few months
the kent variant will stay the
predominant strain
so the clear message really to people is
to have confidence in the
oxaloastrozenica vaccine and to take it
up when offered
because it's likely almost certainly to
provide
excellent protection against severe
illness
you say that the kent variant is likely
to stay the dominant variant for the
next
few months but could that change as more
people
get vaccinated could we see the south
african variant becoming more prevalent
well we do know that the this virus is
very agile and it's it's
raison etc to transmit and therefore it
will be looking at all sorts of ways to
try and transmit
even amongst people that have been
vaccinated and people that have already
had the illness
and so this is why it's so important
that we have a continual two-prong
effort for this
vaccinate as many people as possible but
have clear social distancing and other
physical measures
distancing measures to prevent
transmission and if we can do both in
tandem
get a large proportion of the population
immunize
and maintain social distancing then we
will get on top of this virus
but we will probably because it mutates
so frequently we will probably have to
live with it
but it will circulate and cause disease
in a much more mild fashion
and it is my belief that we will end up
having to have
an annual coronavirus vaccine for the
for coming years probably tailored to
the
predominant uh variant strains which is
circulating in the uk at the time
at the time but but the clear message
really at the moment is to to for people
to take up that vaccine when offered
because it is our
major route out of this pandemic
and and these vaccines are so effective
we are so
fortunate to have such fabulous
scientists that have been working so
hard over the world to produce these
vaccines
and it's quite miraculous really that
they are so effective
right the way across the board that's
the messenger rna vaccines the viral
vector vaccines
and the protein subunits and wholesale
vaccines so
so lots of different types of vaccines
lots of opportunities to tweak and edit
them
um but let's just get vaccinated as
quickly as possible
and let's go very slowly in terms of how
we release the lockdown
lord adeboye britain's black and ethnic
minority communities have
been more likely to die from covet 19
but also
more likely to not take up the vaccine
how concerned should we be about this
well i think the vaccine has been the
rule out of
the vaccine has been an absolute triumph
of science strategy
and delivery by nhs nhs staff it really
is truly remarkable
um it looks like we're going to hit the
target um this
this week um touching about 13 million
but we are in danger of of hitting the
target we're missing the point and the
point is that we have to vaccinate
everybody and we can't leave anyone
behind and
we should be very concerned about the um
the vaccine hesitancy
not just in black and minority ethnic
communities um
but in in other communities as well and
of course we need to ensure
that the homeless and those that are
vulnerable for other reasons
get access to to the vaccine but i am
very concerned about the
disproportionality the first 10 people
to die in the nhs were all people of
color
and we are seeing disproportionate take
up of the vaccine
and vaccine hesitancy at worrying levels
in the black and minority ethnic
community and that should concern
that should concern us all it does feel
like one of the lessons from
the first wave was how
disproportionately more people from
black and minority ethnic communities
were
affected do you think we learned that
lesson later on or not
i think that we are learning that lesson
and it's all too late in in a sense
you know it is obvious um if you look at
the
the people who are most likely to um
have worse experience
of many nhs services worse outcomes they
are
they are members of our black minority
ethnic communities
so it does follow that in a pandemic
they will also suffer because they tend
to be
in the poorest areas doing the
front-line jobs that are least paid so
if if you address the issue of
inequality and inequity
then by definition you will also address
people from black and minority ethnic
communities
and that's a lesson we have painfully
learned during this pandemic
and we can't really afford to learn
again
sarah j marsh test and trace not only
failed to prevent lockdown once
but twice what went wrong and should we
be any
more hopeful that it's going to actually
work in the future
yes i think the testing trace journey
has got many successes in it and many
things that clearly needed to be done
better i think one of the challenges
that we face from the starting testing
trace is the time that we
had to go live with it many of us that
were in the test and trace leadership
team
actually came into post in mid-may and
we had to get the service up and running
um in june we knew that so you know
there was literally days to create
um something of the scale and complexity
that was needed um to keep everybody
safe in the country or as part of the
response to keep everybody safe
and i think that lots of things about
testing trace
have been a success we didn't have
the testing capacity um when the
pandemic first started
to be able to test more than a handful
of people and we know we got to the 3000
test but we knew that we needed many
more
we went on a massive journey not only to
increase the testing capacity that we
had
but also the way that people could
access the testing itself
you know so that you could go to a local
community center
or um you know you could you could
access it via a gp or through
a local director of public health we
also work really hard to think about how
we could improve the turnaround times
for testing so we could get results back
really quickly
and that we could get those results into
the contact tracing system
but this was all happening and
dynamically it wasn't that we were
having the time to work this out um you
know the numbers all the time and the
challenges that we faced
were great but i do think that we were
learning as we went i mean one of the
things that you know really we put focus
on in june july time
was how we could tip the system from
being very nationally focused
to be much more about working locally as
well
making sure that we've got that
connectivity into local communities for
some of the reasons that victor's just
said
we needed to work alongside people who
understood where the virus was most
likely to be where we might have
asymptomatic people where transmission
risk was
higher so lots of work went into
our relationship with local councils and
i know that that was
slower than some people would have liked
but i do think that
um you know we did start to move that
forwards
so i don't think this testing trace is a
story of something that was
you know everything was perfect or
everything was
was a disaster i think there are lots of
things about it
that were actually done really well and
and now it is starting to work
um you can see the impact you know that
it's making
um i think that in time you know we'll
we will have a system that everybody can
be proud of
when i talk to people about tests on
trace quite often they talk about the
testing aspect
like ramping up testing very quickly and
not so much about the other half of the
name the tracing aspect
and it does feel that you know people
weren't giving enough contacts
to you and those contacts weren't
necessarily being
followed up in a timely sense and then
people weren't even self-isolating if
they were told to as well
i went for a system where we spent more
on tests and trace than the budget for
the fire and the police is that really
good enough
no i i agree that the testing system was
more developed the testing
we were working really hard on it from
january february time whereas the
contact racing system was stood up much
more quickly
in may and it took as i've just
described it took through the summer
really to get the right connectivity
between the national system and the
local system it's an end-to-end process
as many people have said
there's no point in just doing the
testing and getting a quick result if we
don't act on it
so i think that was definitely you know
a big area of focus for everybody that
worked in test and trace
and there were some real advocates um
throughout you know that were really
talking up and using every opportunity
to
to think about what was stopping people
particularly from isolating we were
hearing many stories back about
people being scared of testing positive
in case it meant that they couldn't go
out to work for example
you know where were they going to get
money from to put food on the table
and there was a big advocacy sort of
approach from
people in nhs testing trace to say how
do we address some of these issues
and how do we support people and to
isolate
but again i think you can see um as the
data has kind of evolved over the last
few months that actually it is now more
of an end-to-end system
and that we are identifying more
contacts kind of
collectively that's both through the
national system and through the local
contract racing systems as well
the two things are working hand in hand
and we are starting to see
um some some improvements there but i do
think
you know sort of going back to lessons
learned we were working hard on the
testing system from
february the contact racing element
didn't didn't start in earnest really
until may and i think we some of the
issues that we saw were because
some of that disparity and when the the
different elements of the system
really got underway okay interesting
thank you now
we've become used to seeing graphs like
this showing how the viruses
ebbed and flowed since it first emerged
but all of those statistics are of
course
people individuals families lives turned
upside down and one of them
is ali's psychology who is believed to
be britain's longest suffering covered
patient
he and his daughter jay uh join us now
thank you
so much for being on the programme um
how do you think you contracted
covered 19 well that's uh
everyone keeps asking me that i don't i
can't really say for sure where i got it
from you know
it's one of those things that's just
happened i don't i can't it could be
from a shop it could be from anywhere
really
so i can't tell you specifically where i
actually caught it from
and how it was
yeah it was around uh end of march i
actually
caught caught it so um that's
i i got a slight cough and uh my
temperature was rising so i found that
my daughter
shenny's and i actually told her and she
said to me to ring one one one
that's when i rang 111 and they told me
to stay at home
self isolate and if it gets any worse
i should bring them back and after 24
hours 30 hours
i started to get you know breathing
problems i was coughing them much more
and that's when my daughter actually she
phoned 9.99
for the ambulance to come and get me so
when they did
arrive they put me on these machines and
did tests
on my oxygen levels and they were really
low and they
they sort of rushed me to the hospital
and then um
that's when they were doing these tests
and putting a mask
on and other machines on me and
to do other tests and that's when i had
a heart attack
so then they rushed me to king's college
hospital by then i was
like i was unconscious you know i can't
remember
actually getting to king's college
hospital but this is when they told me
afterwards that i had a heart attack
and then they done a surgery on me they
put stealth in you know into my heart
and then my lung collapsed while they
were doing the surgery
so then there was other complications
and then
when i actually did wake up you know
which i thought was the next day it was
10 weeks later you know my daughters
were telling me and my girlfriend
they were saying to me you know on on
what what's that face time or whatever
that
i've been i've been asleep for 10 weeks
you know and i couldn't believe it and
in the meantime i had liver failure
kidney failure lung failure
i had sepsis in my lungs you know i had
gangrene
i was on machines i was on a ventilator
i was having problems with breathing and
i was putting up loads of phlegm and i
was in a bad way
and you know when my kids were telling
me all this i just couldn't believe you
know i just thought it was the next day
but it was 10 weeks later and i was
still in a bad way
and um you know gradually i was getting
better but it took
it took a while you know what an
incredible fight
you really had how are you feeling now
i'm feeling a lot better you know the
fight was that
thankfully for the nhs the support of my
girlfriend and
the support of my kids you know they
were important and they helped me
through that
vital time especially the nhs the
physios the doctors the nurses
you know my kids my girlfriend all their
support
you know i'm feeling a lot better than i
was i'm still about 50
60 you know i've still got a long way to
go because when i woke up i actually
couldn't move a muscle
so you can imagine you know i'm laying
now i can't move i just go back
and breathe you know i'm on a machine
you know troops coming out my throat
so you know i was pretty bad you know
and um
i'm getting better every day is a new
day
so every day i'm i'm getting better yeah
it was lovely to see you both smiling
and talking about getting better in we
wish you
the very very best in your road to
recovery what incredible story thank you
both very much
lord and i mean what a story it just
really
demonstrates the pressures that the nhs
has been under
dealing with these very complex cases
and so many individual stories
this has changed well first of all i
hope that you continue to get better
that is a
hell of a fight that you've been through
and it tells the story of how the nhs
has worked together as a team
to not just deal with the with the with
the acute affairs but also the recovery
and you know we are now talking about a
new service that we need to provide in
the nhs
and my colleagues are talking about
long-covered cases now over the
over 100 000 and it's not just the
physical
issues it's also the mental health
issues and when i talk to
my colleagues in the mental health
networks what they're telling me is that
we're looking at 10 million additional
cases
as a direct result of covid so this has
changed the share
of the kinds of services that the nhs
will need to deliver
going forward and we have to build that
into any kind of credible recovery
mr hunt there are reports the government
is looking at restructuring the nhs do
you think
we do need to look at how we structure
and fund the nhs going forward and like
what's happened
well i think we need to make this a
really big moment in the nhs's history
because it's just been through the
biggest challenge
and and frankly it's come out with
flying colours i'm
ali's story is amazing every single
patient
who's needed a ventilator who's needed
an intensive care bed
has got one and you know as a country we
haven't got everything right
in our pandemic handling but i think the
nhs can be very proud of what it's done
but nhs staff are absolutely exhausted
because they've got the double whammy of
of 25 000 odd covid patients
and the backlog of all the cancer
surgery the hips the knees and so on
that have to be done
so i think the one thing that we could
really do for nhs staff
this year is to put in place a long-term
plan
to sort out the workforce shortages
i don't think we've ever really been
good at training enough doctors and
nurses for the future
i increased training places by 25 in my
time it was a huge increase but
now i'm not sure that even that was
enough
and i think what nhs staff would like to
know they know it takes seven years to
train a doctor three years to train a
nurse
you can't solve these problems overnight
but they'd like to know that there was a
proper plan in place
so that over time we can start to deal
with some of these gaps in the workforce
that create so much stress
well let's talk a bit more about
hospitals shall we because hospitals
really are the front line
in the war against coronavirus daily
battles and intensive care like the one
we just heard from
the difference between life and death
and that statistic that we just heard
from
jeremy hunt because over the last year
despite all
of these deaths not a single coronavirus
patient was denied
a hospital bed or a ventilator but
that's come at a huge cost both
financially
and as we've been discussing in care
homes as well
now on the 17th march in anticipation of
an influx of covered cases nhs england
sends this letter to hospital trust
saying that patients who are medically
fit to leave should be sent home
or crucially to a care home now on the
third of april the country's first
nightingale hospital opens in london to
provide extra capacity and to treat
covert 19
patients the 12th of april is the peak
of the first wave now at this point
there are 21 686 patients with covert 19
in hospital
and there are 3301 on mechanical
ventilators it's also the day that boris
johnson
is discharged from hospital and what's
happening in hospitals is now a real
worry when
sage meets two days later they warn that
there is
significant transmission in hospitals
the 20th of april is the start of a week
where the pandemic's impact on
non-covert treatment begins to show
urgent cancer referrals are down 62
percent
6 000 fewer people are able to receive
chemotherapy
since the first lockdown began now we're
into summer now
and with numbers starting to fall matt
hancock declares that we are winning
the battle against coronavirus some
lockdown measures are eased
schools start to reopen just over six
weeks later on the 17th of july the
prime minister
announces an additional 3 billion pounds
of funding to the nhs
in england to get ready for winter
on the 17th of september sage discusses
scenarios where hospital admissions
double
every seven to nine days they warn that
this does have the potential
to overwhelm the nhs and by the 8th of
october the group says that hospital
admissions in england
are now exceeding their reasonable worst
case scenario planning
and mpis that's non-pharmaceutical
interventions like lockdowns
are needed now let's go to the 17th of
december and just look now how those
hospital numbers
have really jumped sage discusses those
they say this the full effect of the
festive period will not be apparent
until january
even a short period of epidemic growth
could lead to the number of new hospital
admissions in early january 2021
exceeding the peak of the first wave and
on boxing day
that's exactly what happens the number
of covert 19 patients in uk hospitals is
now at its highest point
ever and it's still rising
by new year's eve it's estimated that
one in eight people in england had
covered in december
and sky news reveals that the intensive
care units in
three london hospitals have now reached
full capacity
now this is the first stage meeting of
2021 the 7th of january let's have a
look at the minutes
mortality reductions from vaccination
will not begin to be seen before the end
of january
at the very earliest more likely it will
be later in february
the pressures on the nhs will take
longer to reverse
24 hours later sadiq khan declares a
major incident
in london if we don't take immediate
action now
at nhs could be overwhelmed and more
people
will die he says three days later boris
johnson warns of a perilous moment
during a visit to bristol
in south end hospital this letter is
circulated to staff about the use of
oxygen
it says we've reached a critical
situation with oxygen supply
it's imperative we use oxygen safely
and efficiently now the next day sky
news reveals that during the pandemic
excess deaths rose by more than in any
year
since 1940 and this
the 18th of january this is the peak
of the winter wave of patients in
hospital with covid19
over 14 000 more people are seriously
unwell now than during the first wave
six days later the number of patients on
ventilators is reaches its highest
level ever as sky's home editor jason
farrell reveals the pressure
on exhausted medics who are battling to
keep kovac 19 patients alive
at london's royal free hospital i feel
like i want to cry
in many moments i mean i can do my job
properly what's been the toughest
toughest thing for you
well basically i mean a lot of people
are passing away
and you have to keep doing your job when
you have
a gentleman or a lady that is passed
away and is
lying next to you and basically
we just need to keep going and wait for
somebody else to come and take care of
that and
it's horrible
we could speak now to someone who will
only recognize that too well
dr charlotte summers an intensive care
consultant who sits on the council
of the intensive care society thank you
so much
for being with us what has the last year
been like
i think it's fair to say that for me and
everybody who works in intensive care
it's been the most challenging year that
any of us can remember
we have in many cases not returned to
what we would recognize as being
pre-pandemic intensive care at any point
there are many icus that have never
actually got back to having their
pre-pandemic bed footprint
because when the covert of wave one went
away all of the patients
um that had non-co rhinovirus related
illnesses um increased so for the whole
of the summer we were doing
more work than we would most summers
relating to
things that didn't get dealt with all
the things that worsened wave one of the
pandemic
um and just when we've recovered from
that we've had a second wave which has
been even worse than the first so it's
been a really challenging year
do you think the lessons were learned
from the first wave
of the virus in preparing for what we've
seen this winter
i think in intensive care actually we
learnt a huge amount
over the last year about caring for
patients with this
virus and for being prepared for future
surges
so i think actually a lot of knowledge
sharing and lessons were learned
do i think nationally that we got
everything right no of course not but
there have been some things that have
gone
really quite well to you and how has it
been
one of the things i always think about
how difficult it must be showing the
humanity that you would normally give to
people
in hospital in intensive care being able
to see their loved ones
being able to have that face-to-face
contact how hard has
that been not to be able to do
everything you would normally like
that has been probably one of the most
extraordinarily hard
bits of the pandemic because our
patients families would normally be at
the bedside so normally we would be
having those conversations with them
ourselves face to face and explaining
what was going on and they could see
what was happening
and we would be able to when bad news
needed breaking
do it in person now we've been having to
do that via things like this so via zoom
or skype
or telephone and that is extraordinarily
hard for
the loved ones of our patients for our
patients themselves
but also for staff i think all of us
have found it one of the most
challenging aspects of the pandemic for
us
yeah i can imagine that must be
unbelievably difficult for
nhs staff already under so much pressure
as well
lots of um people as well talk about a
typical covert 19 patient but are you
seeing a real range of people in your
intensive care awards
yes i think a lot of people have got an
image of someone who's
possibly older and has coexisting
health issues i think it's important for
us to remember that half of people
who've been admitted to intensive care
units
are under the age of 60 throughout this
pandemic so half my patients
are working age people who are of an
age that they're very much like the
staff in intensive care
um so you know people my age people
younger than my age
people the same age as my partner and
other people's husbands and loved ones
um i think it's important to remember
that there is no typical
carina virus patient there is a spectrum
from people who are very young to people
who are
more elderly both in intensive care and
where 90 percent of people
with coronavia looked after in hospitals
which is outside the intensive care unit
thank you so much for sharing a bit with
us about what it's been like you know
working in these intensive care units
over the last 12 months we really thank
you for your work as well thank you
i just want to pick up on something that
was just said there about non-covered
illnesses sarah j marsh are you worried
about how people
without covert 19 has suffered during
the last 12 months
first wave for example urgent cancer
referrals down
62 are we looking at a health care time
bomb here
yeah and i think our nhs staff have done
an absolutely amazing job on looking
after
patients with codeine have done our
absolute best to keep other essential
services going i mean in my area
maternity
you know nobody told the babies about
the pandemic and they've kept coming
so in services like maternity and our
mental health services
we have kept going and you know are
continuing to deliver
really fantastic services in difficult
circumstances
but there are some things that we simply
can't do as you've said we know there
are people
sort of waiting uh urgent cancer
treatment there are people living in
in pain we know we won't be able to give
their operation
than their operations in a timely way
and i think this is a huge source of
distress
and to many people who work in the nhs
uh we're there because we want to be
able to provide that high quality
service to everybody who needs us it's
one of the
founding principles of the nhs and to
not to be able to do that it is a big
worry and at the moment
we're just planning how we do that we
fingers crossed appear to be
um you know coming down uh out now of
the current
peak which means that we can start to
think about how we recover some of
our services but we have to accept that
alongside
restoring our services we have to
restore our people as well
you can't ask people to work in these
really difficult conditions you know
wearing all of these ppe long shifts
working outside of their areas
outside of their roles sometimes outside
of their organization
to just get back to normal next monday
and i think this balance between sort of
recovering our
our people and being able to recover our
services is probably
for you know me and my colleagues the
chief executive community probably you
know one of the biggest challenges that
we'll face in our careers
lord adeboye do you think the pandemic
has exposed issues with the structure of
the nhs would you
welcome for example reported reforms
giving the health secretary more control
well look the nhs didn't go into the
pandemic in a
in a in an excellent state we were
already a hundred
thousand down um in terms of staff
vacancies
um we're now about 87 000 down and about
38 000 nurses short
there were already some issues around
you know investment
so we went into it went into the
pandemic
with some issues what the nhs has
achieved
uh is truly remarkable sarah and her
colleagues
have pulled this country through one of
the worst crisis in living memory and
continue to do so
and we have to respect that and you know
i think that we need we owe it to them
to think carefully about how we support
them
through the next phase which is about
recovery and i absolutely agree as do
many of my members
across the nhs not just those in acute
hospitals but the mental health trust
community
primary care we owe it to them to really
plan
the run into um a different kind of of
nhs and
that's one in which we work together
that's one in which health and social
care
are integrated it's one in which we have
population health structures delivered
and you know what
i'm not really going to get into a
debate about
you know whether the secretary of state
has more or less control or not i sat on
the board of nhs england for six years
i think it's perfectly reasonable the
secretary of state should have lie on
the site of how we spend well over
160 billion pounds the question is
the secretary of state and politicians
need to give
appropriate authority to those people
who understand their populations
understand how population health can
work and should work
give them the authority to plan
carefully and deliver the services that
those populations need
if we can do that then we can turn this
around and we can learn from the
pandemic
in a really in a really in a magnificent
way because
the wish to do it the wish to deliver
health care
has has not has not been diminished by
the pandemic the
the leadership and the delivery in the
nhs is truly remarkable
and they deserve a leadership at the top
just to support them
i want to talk about care homes um
almost a third
of all cover deaths came from care home
residents and right now we're seeing
destin care homes rising to levels that
we haven't seen
since the first peak but people can
still be discharged
from care homes without a negative test
mr hunt what happened to the protective
ring that was supposed to be thrown
around care homes
well we've clearly got to learn lessons
i think we have learned lots of lessons
about that
in germany they had a rule that if you
couldn't quarantine someone in a care
home
with full protection of the other staff
and and other residents then
care homes weren't allowed to accept
people from hospitals and
that was one of the things we didn't do
last year now when people are discharged
into care homes
uh enormous precautions are taken and we
do need to free up
hospital beds as well but i would just
echo something that lord adeboye said
when we are planning the future of the
nhs
we also need to do the same for the
social care system
because i think one of the things that
has become clear to the whole country if
anyone wasn't aware before
is what an amazing job care workers do
often at very
low pay rates they've been under
enormous pressure working in care homes
but also out in the community going
around visiting vulnerable people
and i think we have a 10-year plan for
the nhs which i think has been
welcomed by the nhs i think it's time we
had a 10-year plan for the social care
system and for the social care workforce
to give them that long-term
confidence that we're addressing some of
the very entrenched problems
that have existed there for some time
but if they are to be valued
they weren't valued particularly the
beginning of the pandemic they weren't
even given the right ppe were they when
hospitals
were prioritized well
in hong kong they learned after the sars
epidemic that all
care homes were first of all very
vulnerable places and they required
care homes to have three months supply
of ppe and i think that's the kind of
lesson we will
definitely learn for the future so yes
there's a lot that we have to learn
but i think we also have to recognize
that our social care system
was in a very distressed state before
and successive governance including the
one that i was part of
were keen to push forward reforms but
now if we don't do it this time after
we've seen
just how heroic the work has been in the
social care
sector we're never going to do it so i
think this is really the moment when we
have to
grasp the metal on social care reform
professor handen how concerned are you
about the take-up of vaccines among
care-home workers
i'm concerned i think it's i think it's
a real live issue
in fact we we do know that care home
residents have taken up the
um the vaccines in very large numbers
but there are a proportion of care home
staff which still haven't and i think
the message still needs to come across
loud and clear to them that they're not
only protecting themselves
but particularly with the oxford
astrozenica as we know
uh affects transmission that they will
affect um
they will protect their elderly
residents who they really care for
deeply um in potentially contracting the
virus from them
so so it's really important that we
continue to really press home that
message
and i think the message is starting to
get through
um but we still got a long way to go can
i just go back
also to the problems of the health
service um
i do think that the the the way that the
nhs has
tackled this crisis has been nothing
short of miraculous
but i do think going forward we really
do need to look after our workforce
better
i think that you know we don't we not
only need to increase numbers of doctors
and nurses but we need to look after
them
and care for them and make their work
into conditions really good
we also need to one thing that hasn't
come out is we also need to embrace
technology more i
i do believe certainly in primary care
and throughout the health service that
actually technologies have probably
advanced about 10 years during this
pandemic and we're all getting used to
communicating through technological
means now and i think we could really
embrace this within the health service
and make things a lot more efficient
and finally i'd like to say that i do
strongly believe
that we ought to integrate as jeremy
hunts just said
social care health care and public
health in a much better way
and we do need to think very clearly how
we're going to do this
um could be done very easily through
primary care
networks uh but it needs to be thought
about very carefully because it's
the pandemic has brought this really
into sharp
focus that actually the elderly people
that be most affected by this pandemic
also require an awful lot of social care
and integration with their health care
and so we really
really need to look at this very
strongly as a country
and work out how we're going to shape
our nhs
so we look after this demographic
population it does get just going back
a really important point about the
workforce we need to look after the
workforce
they've they've been a beacon of light
during this pandemic
and we need to make sure that they're
valued talking about looking after
people
who should be prioritized next for the
vaccine should we be looking at teachers
as some have called for
well we're quite clear on jcbi that
we've outlined nine
priority groups which go down to the age
of 50.
now of course unfortunately after that
but after that who do you think should
be prioritized well i think we need to
look at the data and we need to see
as your um uh contributor from intensive
care
said there are still a number of young
younger people which are
getting very very sick from this virus
we need to look very carefully
what the risk factors are for severe
illness
then we need to look at other factors
like transmission
who is likely to be transmitting to
others and then we need to look at other
factors like
key workers particularly with those with
occupational
uh health exposure risk so there are a
number of factors to look at
in this phase two but jcb are clear that
disease
and burden of disease still needs to be
really important
in the prioritization list so we will be
looking at all these factors in
combination
and we'll be coming up with a very clear
decision about how we should prioritize
in the next phase of the program
but we do have to remember that all
people will get
that will be offered a vaccine and that
will be in a
relatively short period of time given
the pace that we're rolling out this
vaccination program
so maybe a little bit of patience is
required but we will get to everybody
every adult in this country
before too long when do you think before
too long is just very briefly i'm
running out of time
well well jc i don't set targets but i
do believe donald
on record for say in september but it
may be sooner than that
okay thank you very much uh for all our
panelists for this uh
evening's programme jeremy hunt lord
dada
sarah j maas professor hondan thank you
very much for your contributions thank
you
well that is it for this evening but
tomorrow the british public
gets its say we're going to be joined by
a senior government minister
who is going to be facing the questions
of a virtual studio audience
on everything that we've heard this week
and more so do please join us tomorrow
night
for the final part of coverage crisis
learning the lessons that's at eight
o'clock
here on sky news thank you for watching
and good night
[Music]
you